mit der umbenennung mazedoniens in
republik nord mazedonien wurde im
februar 2009 10 der jahrelange namen
streit beigelegt der weg richtung eu und
nato ist somit frei nord mazedonien und
griechenland haben dabei europa
vorgeführt dass ein jahrzehntelanger
politischer konflikt gelöst werden kann
wenn der wille dazu vorhanden ist heute
in vechta kompakt licht und schatten auf
dem westbalkan
[Musik]
leider ist die allgemeine situation auf
dem westbalkan nicht so
erfolgversprechend wie in nord
mazedonien das negative erbe der zufalls
kriege und alte feindbilder behindern
auch noch nach 20 jahren die entwicklung
guter nachbarschaftlicher beziehungen
wie in anderen ländern europas hat der
nationalismus auch auf dem westbalkan
wieder auftrieb erhalten
autoritäre tendenzen und
vetternwirtschaft haben zugenommen
angels beklagen wachsenden druck auf
unabhängige medien und journalisten in
einigen ländern der region stehen sich
regierung und opposition sehr feindselig
gegenüber das größte potenzielle risiko
für die regionale stabilität geht nach
wie vor von der kosovo-frage aus die
unabhängigkeit der ehemals serbischen
provinz kosovo wird bis heute von
serbien nicht anerkannt der politische
dialog zwischen belgrad und pristina der
hauptstadt des kosovo befindet sich seit
jahren in der krise
auf beiden seiten herrscht tiefes
misstrauen so beschuldigt belgrad die
kosovarische regierung die serben im
nordkosovo einzuschüchtern
die serbische regierung hat nun auch
schon mehrmals militärisch gedroht
sie stufte auch die absicht der
kosovarischen seite eine multi ethnische
armee aufzubauen als aggressiven akt 1
umgekehrt wird die kosovarische
regierung belgrad feindselige
aktivitäten vor
dazu zählen aus der sicht von bricht der
fallen bei graz diplomatische versuche
jene etwas mehr als 100 staaten die
kosovo bisher anerkannt haben zu einer
rücknahme dieser anerkennung zu bewegen
weiters ist ja wie im bestrebt die
aufnahme des kosovo in internationale
organisationen wie zum beispiel interpol
zu verhindern
andererseits ist es nach auffassung
bestehen als vor allem belgrad
dass eine integration der kosovo serben
in kosovo tische institutionen behindert
seit ende 2008 zehn hektar kosovo auch
hohe zölle auf waren aus serbien 1
das hat das verhältnis noch zusätzlich
verschlechtert dennoch hoch die eu dass
es bald zum abschluss eines abkommens
zur normalisierung der beziehungen
zwischen serbien und kosovo kommt diese
hoffnungen ruhen nicht zuletzt auf
andeutungen der präsidenten serbiens und
des kosovo hashim thaci den konflikt
durch eine gebiets abtausch lösen zu
holen
allerdings gibt es auch starken
widerstand gegen die idee geht nicht der
die totale aufteilungen viele kosovo
albaner sehen den teilungsplan eine
gefahr für die existenzsicherung im
staat ist ein teil der große rosen hat
hingegen angst im falle energie
bestellung den kosovo verlassen zu
müssen
nachbarländer befürchten dass politische
hardliner vor allem in bosnien
herzegowina bei ihren sezession
bestrebungen ermutigt werden könnten
zweifelsohne ist es gefährlich bei der
lösung offener fragen am westbalkan zur
des kranken rezepten zurückzukehren
erfolgreiche europäische modelle der
konfliktlösung wie zum beispiel
kulturelle autonomie kommunale
selbstverwaltung und minderheitenschutz
bieten sich hier an
wie steht es mit der nato und eu
integration die europäische union sieht
sich derzeit mit vielen
herausforderungen konfrontiert auch die
politische unterstützung für
neuaufnahmen hat nachgelassen
dennoch bleibt die eu für die
westbalkanstaaten der wichtigste
internationale partner bei der
durchführung demokratische reformen und
bei der verbesserung der beziehungen in
südosteuropa unternehmer und serbien
führen bereits konkrete
eu-beitrittsverhandlungen albanien und
nord mazedonien offen auf den raschen
beginn solche gespräche bosnien
herzegowina wartet auf den
kandidatenstatus die
beitrittsperspektive des kosovo ist in
folge der nicht anerkennung durch fünf
eu staaten stark eingeschränkt
die nato integration der ws balkanländer
erfolgreicher grad sowie albanien und
montenegro sind bereits beigetreten nord
mazedonien sollte bis spätestens 2020
das dreißigste nato mitglied werden
die repräsentanten von bosnien
herzegowina sind 71 und dieser staat der
nato überhaupt beitreten soll
serbien hat sich für militärisch neutral
erklärt und strebt keine nato beitreten
ein kurzer ausblick der westbalkan ist
jetzt seit einer nur halb konsolidierte
region und bleibt auf eine umfassende
unterstützung der eu angewiesen
dazu gehört auch die fortsetzung der
friedensmissionen in posen und
herzegowina sowie im kosovo zu denen das
österreichische bundesheer maßgeblich
beiträgt
es liegt im interesse der eu die länder
des westbalkan zu integrieren auch
deshalb um europa feindliche kräfte
nicht zu stärken um zu verhindern dass
die staaten der region in fremde
abhängigkeiten geraten